in the very beginning there was nothing
just an empty void then came chaos the
first of all of primordial deities to
appear in the great cosmos every god and
goddess that features in greek mythology
has somewhat descended from chaos and
today we'll be taking a look at what
many consider to be her first child nyx
the goddess of night there are different
stories and versions of greek mythology
when NYX was considered to be the first
primal to a deity assumed in the role of
creator that we generally associated
with chaos but we'll be focusing on her
depiction there's a daughter of chaos
today NYX was born at a time when the
world as we know it didn't really exist
her and her siblings Gaia Tartarus and
Arabists were amongst the four first
deities born from chaos that would shape
the world with Nixon Eris being two of
the earliest primordial deities we can
assume that the world was shrouded in
darkness Erebus himself after all was
the personification of darkness and
shadows this would however eventually
change when Nixon irbaz partner together
they produced aether and hemella aether
beam light and her Mara be in day the
exact opposite to their parents night
and darkness depictions of NYX like many
of the other primordial deities can vary
drastically as many of them are thought
to represent abstract or specific
concepts NYX in her literal form would
be the night that surrounds us in her
physical form she was either shown as
being an extremely beautiful woman
dressed in black surrounded by a dark
mist
sometimes ride in a chariot or as a
winged goddess with a halo made from a
dark cloud NYX being one of the oldest
deities in Greek mythology meant that
she had numerous children including
Thanatos the god of death Hypno's the
god of sleep morose the god of doom Eris
the goddess of strife nemesis the
goddess of divine retribution the karez
bring us a violent death the honorary
that bringers of Dreams and in some
cases she was even mother to the Moriah
the three goddesses of fate
NIC's and many of the other primordial
deities were believed to reside in the
depths of Tartarus a common belief was
that during the day both Nix and Erebus
would lay dormant in the darkest
crevices of Tartarus and each night they
would emerge hand-in-hand together as
they blocked the light that was emitted
by aether bringing darkness and in turn
the night to the world
the following morning himera just as her
parents had done previously would emerge
from Tartarus and sweep away the
darkness leaving her mother and father
to return the cycle meant that Nixon
spent much time off her daughter as they
were never in the same place for very
long and it's likely that the ancient
Greeks used the story of nix and her
children as one of the first
explanations of the night and day cycle
this story did of course change when a
us became the goddess of dawn and the
roles of eighth and Ameri
would be replaced by Helios and Apollo
Nix however was never really replaced
throughout Greek mythology and this
could be because the ancient Greeks
considered her to be extremely powerful
and as a result held her in high regard
regardless of how she was viewed Nix
still doesn't really feature in many
stories there are those that believe
when Cronus castrated his father he did
so in the cover of night and thus he was
protected by the goddess but perhaps one
of the most famous stories featuring Nix
involves one of her children
Hypno's was asked by Hera to place loose
into a deep slumber
so she could plot against him hypnose
attempted to do as Hera asked but he
wasn't powerful enough to keep Zeus
asleep for very long and when Zeus awoke
he pursued hypnose relentlessly fearing
for his life he did the only thing that
he knew would keep him safe and fled to
his mother's cabin in Tartarus when Zeus
eventually learned of where hypnose had
gone he decided against pursuing that
god any further for fear of anger and
NYX in some variations it was actually
Nix who found Zeus and persuaded him to
stop the pursuit of his son even
receiving an apology from Zeus
Nyx's a goddess that many saw as a
facilitator to some of our darkest
desires and even most horrendous actions
be it two lovers sneaking out to see Jeb
under the cover of dusk or a murder
being committed in the shadows of night
many also saw Nix as a protector
fugitives often looked and prayed
towards Nix hope and shield grant them
safe passage in the night she was a
goddess extremely feared even by Zeus
which is something that definitely
doesn't happen too often in Greek
mythology and I feel it raises an
interesting point of discussion it's
pretty common for people to say that
they're afraid of the dark or the night
but you'll also hear these same people
tell you that it's not actually the
darkness they're afraid of but rather
what hides in the darkness the fear of
uncertainty can make one feel helpless
the gods and goddesses may not have
actually been scared of Nix but rather
the darkness she brings and what is
concealed behind it whether you believe
that Nix was the very first primordial
deity or at least one of the earliest
there's no denying that she was an
extremely influential and powerful
figure she was responsible for the very
first notion of the night and day cycle
and along with essentially creating the
light and the day she gave birth to many
children who performed the vital and
influential roles what I personally find
most interesting about Nix is that she's
a goddess that many people are familiar
with but she's never really given a
defining set of characteristics we know
that she was widely respected and feared
but we don't know much else she's a
goddess that you could interpret the way
you'd like to you can choose to see her
as the literal night that surrounds us
or a powerful woman shrouded in darkness
bringing the night to wherever she goes
I'd love to know what you guys think
Nix has got a select been requested to
do a video about for a very long time so
how do you feel about her now issue got
us that you would have liked to have
seen mentioned more or does the element
of mystery and uncertainty surrounding
Nix add to her character let me know in
the comments below as always I've been
your host mythology and fiction
explained
you